what i want to do in this video is talk
a little bit about traditional
traditional
iras
and ira stands for individual retirement
account
individual
retirement
account
and the focus on this video is the
traditional ira you'll hear of other
types of iras especially roth iras and
sep iras but this is only untraditional
the gist of all of them is really
it's the government's way of encouraging
you to save for your retirement but they
all have slightly different details so
i'm just going to focus on the
traditional right now
so let's say
we are in year 0
that's right now instead of year 0 let
me write right now
and you have two options you could put
you could take advantage of the
traditional ira so this is the ira
scenario
and this is the no ira
no ira scenario
now an ira allows you to put up to a
certain amount of your income
aside now depending on your age and what
year it is that amount will change but
in 2010 that number is five thousand
dollars
five thousand dollars if you're under
the age of 50
for
under
50 and it's six thousand dollars this is
for an individual not for a family and
it's six thousand dollars
six thousand dollars if you're over the
age
over the age of 50 over age
of 50. i guess the rationale was
probably gee if you're over the age of
50 you better save even more for your
retirement which might only be 10 or 15
years away so they give a little bit
more leeway for over the age of 50.
so let's say we take we're under the age
of 50 and we take full advantage
of this ira so we set aside five
thousand dollars
five thousand dollars here we set aside
nothing
set
aside
nothing
now in the very short term the
advantages is that this 5 000 of our
income will not be taxed so let's say
that let's say that my tax bracket let's
say i'm in a 32 percent tax bracket
tax
bracket let me write that on the side
because it'll apply to both scenarios
tax
bracket today
because i'm making some good money
tax bracket today so if i on the five
thousand dollars only i'm only talking
about the taxes on the five thousand
dollars you have to pay taxes above and
beyond that on the rest of your income
but today i'm going to pay zero taxes on
that five thousand dollars so zero
taxes
on
the five thousand dollars
now if i don't set aside that five
thousand dollars into an ira
then i will have to pay taxes on that
five thousand dollars so i'm gonna have
to pay
five thousand
five thousand times
thirty two percent which is equal to
what that is i'll just get the
calculator out
so you get
5 000
times 0.32
is equal to 1600 in taxes
so i'm gonna pay
sixteen hundred dollars
in taxes
in
taxes
today
so in the year that i actually made that
five thousand dollars now i can't set
aside five thousand dollars if i made
less than five thousand dollars it's
always the lower of your income or these
ira
limits and of course you're going to pay
even in this situation let's say you
made a hundred thousand dollars when you
put the five thousand aside you're still
gonna have to pay taxes on ninety five
thousand dollars in this situation where
you didn't put the five thousand dollars
aside you're gonna have to pay taxes on
a hundred thousand dollars so you're
gonna have to pay taxes on the extra
five thousand dollars which is sixteen
hundred dollars now let's say let's go
over let's say in either situation with
that five thousand dollars you wanna buy
and sell some
some securities or some investments
so let's say
right after you put it in the ira
account so now everything is sitting in
our ira account all of our transactions
are sitting in this special
ira account right here where we can
actually buy and sell investments and
trade them but we can't cash them in and
turn them into cash and then spend it on
a new car or something like that so and
if we did do that before the age of 59
and a half we'd have to pay a penalty so
let me write that down you might
immediately say hey gee this is a good
deal why why do doesn't everyone always
do it well the answer is if i pull it
out before 59 and a half i pay a penalty
let me write this down because that's
important to keep in mind pay
penalty
penalty and taxes
and taxes if withdrawn
if
withdrawn
before
59 and a half and once again this is
what this is the traditional ira the
roth ira for example is a little bit
more flexible on the the actual
principal amount that you put into the
account but we're just dealing with
traditional so this is an important
thing to keep in mind this is kind of
the trade-off that you're giving so the
government saying hey i'm giving you an
incentive to put this aside and i really
want to make sure that you leave this
aside until you already retire you don't
get tempted when you know when you see a
nice sports car to cash in your ira and
use it because you're going to have to
pay a penalty but as long as you don't
actually withdraw it and turn it into
cash you can actually buy and sell
securities within that ira so let's say
as soon as you put that five thousand
dollars you buy five thousand dollars
five thousand dollars
of stock
a
here we don't have five thousand dollars
anymore we only have thirty four hundred
dollars of our original amount
so we buy thirty four hundred dollars
thirty four hundred dollars
of
stock
a
and let's say i don't know ten years in
the future
so let's say in ten years
ten years that's going to be in either
situation
in 10 years let's say that stock a has
doubled so in 10 years stock and you
sell it
so now you sell it you have ten thousand
dollars here
you have ten thousand dollars from
sale
of a it's doubled here it's doubled but
you only had thirty four hundred dollars
of stock a so now that thirty four
hundred dollars is worth sixty eight
hundred dollars so you have sixty eight
hundred dollars
from
sale
of
a and let's say you want to put that
into
another stock so let's say you put that
all into stock b and i'm painting a very
rosy picture you can't always ensure
that stocks will double and then so you
buy ten thousand dollars in this
situation ten thousand dollars
of
b
and and i'll hold off there so you buy
ten thousand dollars of b and here you
might say oh i'm gonna buy sixty eight
hundred dollars of b but because you are
not operating within an ira account you
are you're going to have to pay taxes on
the capital gains from this right here
so capital gains are gains made from
capital investments in this case the
capital investment is investing in
stocks and since you owned your stock
for more than one year you at least will
only have to pay long-term capital gains
which tends to be small lower than
short-term capital gains so in this
situation you made thirty four hundred
dollar profit
thirty four hundred i wrote three
hundred forty thousand
you made thirty four hundred dollar
profit
you're going to have to pay 15 capital
gains
times 15
times 15 let's get the calculator out
again
so
times 0.15
it's 510 dollars you're going to have to
pay 510 dollars so this is 510 dollars
so you take your 6800 pay 510 dollars to
the irs you are going to be
left with
you're going to be left with 60 what is
that 62
6290 remember this the reason why you
have to pay taxes is this is not
operating inside of an ira here you are
operating inside of an ra so you don't
have to pay taxes now let's say you
invest in stock b and then over the next
10 years stock b also doubles
so stock so this is 10
years so stock b is
now worth twenty thousand dollars and
you sell it from sale
from sale
of
b and once again it's sitting inside of
your ira so you don't have to pay any
capital gains on it now in this
situation you use that 62 6290
to also invest in stock b
and after 10 years 10 years
stock b doubles so it is now what is
that twelve thousand
five hundred and eighty dollars but once
again it's sitting outside of your ira
you have to pay fifteen percent capital
gains you had a six thousand two hundred
and ninety gain
six thousand two hundred and ninety
dollar
gain times fifteen percent
let's see what that is
let's get the calculator where's my
calculator there it is
so you have six thousand
ninety
times
is equal to 943 and let me take that
from my 12 580 12 580
minus
943.5
is equal to so i have 11
636 dollars
so i now have
thirty six dollars and let's say 20
years have passed we are now over the
age of 59 and a half we can now withdraw
from our ira
now of course this situation this is
cash that we have we can do anything
with it maybe we're now over 60 years
old this could be used for our
retirement for our everyday expenses now
this money that was sitting in an ira
now that we're over the age of 60
we're over 60 now
or over 59 and a half if you want to be
particular
now that we're over 60 we can withdraw
the ira without paying any penalty but
we will have to pay taxes
so we will have so let's we're going to
withdraw
no penalties but we we will have to pay
taxes but the huge advantage here is
once we're over 60 we're probably
earning less money so the actual tax
bracket that we're in is probably going
to be lower so let's say we're in a 25
percent
tax bracket remember when we first made
that five that five thousand dollars we
were in a 32 tax bracket because we were
you know this this young gun at the peak
of his or her career making a lot of
money
now we're making less money we're
starting to live off of our savings so
we have to pay 25 income tax on it so if
we pay 25 on 20 000 remember now we're
actually withdrawing it we're actually
putting it into our checking account so
we could spend it for for a living or
whatever we want to do with it
so 25 of 20 000 is equal to 5 000
in taxes so we will be left with
we will be left with 15
to do anything that we want with it now
compare this this is fifteen thousand
dollars versus eleven thousand six
hundred and thirty six dollars and
everything we did was completely
identical except for over here we took
the 500 sorry the five thousand dollars
and invested within an ira here we took
the five thousand dollars we had to pay
taxes on it
then we invested it in the exact same
way we actually made very good stock
investments in both situations and we
ended up with a significant
less amount of money i mean this is a
you know fifteen thousand versus eleven
thousand that's almost what is that a
thirty something percent difference in
the total amount of money has and not
only that but this tax we had to pay
this tax we have to pay we had we don't
have to pay this this is only a
situation we have 25 tax rate when
you're retired you might even have a
lower tax rate than that and it's
deferred a good bit but the real thing
to think about is just 20 years in the
future you're sitting on fifteen
thousand dollars versus if you didn't
participate in an ira you're sitting on
only a little over 11
and a half thousand dollars and of
course the main trade-off here is is
that in the ira situation you really
couldn't touch your money so if you had
an emergency and you had to withdraw the
money you would have had to pay
penalties on it